the 2010's were full of capes and tights
on the big screen and as we look back at
the past 10 years it's time to discuss
the best superhero movies of the last
decade even after the first trailer hit
the Avengers a movie with multiple
superheroes teaming up on the big screen
felt like something that couldn't
possibly work then the film arrived and
it was an absolute blast the Avengers is
certainly not a perfect film but it
inspired a sense of all simply by
existing and being as fully formed and
solid as it was there's a certain
miraculous quality to that particular
team-up held with humor in heart by
writer director Joss Whedon that makes
it feel magical Avengers movies are a
pop culture language all their own now
but back then it was hard to imagine
something like this working so well that
it still works nearly a decade later as
proof that the Avengers was a certain
kind of lightning in a bottle
the idea was to bring together a group
of remarkable people see if they could
become something more to this day The
Dark Knight Rises is a particularly
divisive film among superhero fans still
the thing that sticks out years after
its release is Nolan's an arguable sense
of scope and ambition where the Dark
Knight was often at its best when it
functioned as a psychological duel
between two opposing personalities The
Dark Knight Rises was epic in its scale
and its themes the film is practically
operatic in its Sensibility it remains
the boldest broadest most daring portion
of the Dark Knight trilogy and the gutsy
swings it took are still worth
revisiting now we came here about this
conquerors
but as liberators to return control this
city to the people
Deadpool famously spent years in
development as star Ryan Reynolds
lobbied for an r-rated superhero comedy
that would break the fourth wall and
mock everything from the x-men movies to
Green Lantern even after it was finally
greenlit questions surrounded Deadpool's
ability to execute its meta style for
the full length of a feature film when
the film finally arrived it put all
those questions to rest the movie was a
full blown phenomenon led by Ryan
Reynolds's obviously in the title role
and it proved there was an appetite for
more r-rated superhero fare
Hugh Jackman had been wearing the
Clauses Wolverine for nearly 20 years by
the time he decided to make Logan his
curtain call as the character Jackman's
final Wolverine effort could have been a
glorified cameo in another massive x-men
film instead he and director James
Mangold made sure the character went out
like an old gunslinger and a futuristic
superhero Western from the opening
sequence to the heart-wrenching final
act Logan is the kind of masterpiece
every franchise actor hopes to go out on
with Wonder Woman director patty Jenkins
and star gal gadot gave us a dynamic
fierce film that followed Diana from her
childhood to her first great battle
among mortals the film is packed with
instantly memorable sequences from the
no-man's land battle that became its
centerpiece to Diana and Steve Trevor's
slow-burning romance meanwhile the
supporting casts led by an absurdly
charming Chris Pine made sure that even
the quieter scenes are fun to watch even
now Wonder Woman still stands as a DC
extended universe as very best film
you did this we did thor ragnarok gave
the god of thunder the kind of boundless
science-fiction overtones that he's
often had in his comic book adventures
the film also threw in an added extra
dose of comedy to underline Thor's place
among the most lovably well-intentioned
idiots in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
director take a white tee tees visual
stamp from the brightly colored sets to
the oddly shaped spaceships is all over
the film Ragnarok has proved that even
the most established franchise heroes
can still be refreshed with new blood
there was a lot riding on Black Panther
the first superhero film in the mega
popular Marvel Cinematic Universe to
feature a black lead character and a
primarily black leading cast everyone
wanted it to change the world but they
also wanted a great superhero
blockbuster with the deck stacked
against them director Ryan Coogler and
his cast managed to do both with its
Oscar winning score costumes and
production design the movie tapped into
a culture and mythology rarely seen in
Hollywood movies plus it gave us one of
the best super villains to ever grace
the silver screen Michael B Jordan as
the deadly yet sympathetic Eric kill
monger these arsons on for sale how do
you think your ancestors got these you
think they paid a fair price what did
they take it like they took everything
else black panther absolutely changed
the superhero genre and it's the kind of
film that will remain a touchstone of
the genre for years to come if there's
one superhero who's arguably
oversaturated the big screen in the 21st
century it's spider-man then into the
spider-verse arrived and quickly proved
that there's no such thing as too much
spider-man if you know what you're doing
the film's dynamic and endlessly
compelling animation style killer voice
cast and moving story combined to create
what might just be the best spider-man
movie to date it's a film that
understands the spider-man journey with
such precision that it can communicate
vast emotional truths in the span of a
single moment you leave the theater
believing that anyone really can wear
the mask
directed by Julia Hart's fast color
tells the intimate story of a family the
strange powers they keep and the
troubles that have kept them at a
distance from one another in a dying
world where it hasn't rained in years
Gugu mbatha-raw leads a fantastic small
ensemble of actors as they navigate the
tense emotional landscape of a story
that's as much about family ties as it
about superpowers tents well-crafted and
full of heart fast color is a
masterclass on how to use genre
conventions judiciously it builds and
builds in a patient careful way right up
until a deeply emotionally satisfying
climax in a landscape full of mega
franchises it's a reminder that there
should be room for smaller films like
this because they can often hit us just
as hard as the blockbusters the
concluding film and what Marvel Studios
dubbed the infinity saga Avengers
endgame is like infinity war in that
it's a sprawling ensemble piece with the
fate of the universe at stake beyond
that though the two films diverged in a
number of powerful ways endgame was a
sure thing at the box office but that
didn't stop the team behind it from
taking any number of risks including an
early death scene a major time jump and
of course a time-traveling caper that
takes up a big chunk of the film it's a
swing for the fences with a massive
payoff that covers not just the
three-hour film but the entire previous
decade of filmmaking at Marvel this is
the fight of our lives and we're going
to win
whatever it takes check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite
superhero movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you